saint quentin en yvelines sera à
l'honneur pendant les jo de 2024 quatre
sites ont été retenus par les
organisateurs français les épreuves de
cyclisme sur piste seront programmés
dans le vélodrome nationale la structure
inaugurée en 2014 a déjà accueilli les
championnats du monde en 2015 et les
championnats d'europe l'année suivante
bien sûr ça à lèves le doute sur sur
toutes les interrogations qu'on pourrait
avoir la l'équipement il est là il a été
testé et il a accueilli déjà la plus
grandes échéances internationales avec
les championnats du monde donc je pense
que tout ça fait forcément des garanties
pour le seuil haut à une centaine de
mètres du vélodrome lille de loisirs de
saint quentin en yvelines a été
sélectionné dans le dossier paris 2024
pour accueillir les épreuves masculines
et féminines de bmx une piste modulable
sera construite sur ce terrain vague de
sept hectares
ce site a été choisi principalement
parce qu'ils jour je te le vélodrome on
est on est à 100 mètres à pied du
vélodrome
donc il y aura une parfaite
complémentarité entre les épreuves qui
se dérouleront dans le vélodrome et les
épreuves de bmx ici sans parler du cadre
nature qui s'y prête parfaitement la
colline d'elancourt accueillera quant à
elle les épreuves de vtt le projet dans
les cartons depuis les jo de 2012 a été
ressortie pour la candidature de paris
2024 le site qui culmine à 2 131 mètres
d'altitude fait toujours autant
l'unanimité auprès des organisateurs
pour accueillir les épreuves de vtt
la première force et l'unité de lieu le
deuxième point là ici c'est la
dénivellation et donc le vtt on appelle
ça mountain bike c'est du vélo de
montagne et donc il faut aller chercher
des pentes raides et il ya quasiment
qu'ici qu'on a qu'on a ce que l'on
souhaite pour avoir quelque chose de
très raide donc ouais c'est assez
naturel que ça vienne ici sur la sur la
colline de la hanche
enfin le golf national recevrait les
épreuves golfique les joueurs
disputeront les parties sur le parcours
de l'albatros le 18 trous réputé comme
l'un des plus compliqués au monde a été
entièrement rénové entre 2015 et 2016
cinch a lancé une charge de plus c'est
une super compétition et dans les cadres
légion les bandes nationale c'est le
premier parcours du vol du monde en
dresser wayne ryder cup est légion donc
assez commun mais non ça fait pas peur
c'est simplement goodchild est plus à ça
sa grande émotion à la vie dans le reste
des yvelines les épreuves d'équitation
de pentathlon moderne se disputeront à
versailles les courses de cyclisme sur
route devrait quant à elle passer dans
la vallée de chevreuse